Speaker 1: We appear really genuinely to be
getting to the later phases of fighting the
coronavirus pandemic.
Even with the anti-war sentiment that is plaguing
much of the country, which we've talked about,
we are continuing to get more and more good
news about the next few months in terms of
the battle against the pandemic.
Yesterday, we received really great news that
the Fizer vaccine has been approved for emergency
use for 12 to 15 year olds.
This will allow middle school age students
to be fully vaccinated by the time school
starts in the fall.
We're going to talk more about that approval
a little bit later on in the program.
But the Fizer vaccine has been found to be
100 percent effective in a clinical trial
of more than 2000 adolescents in terms of
protection and creating a robust antibody
response.
That's very, very good news.
We also learned that even with the current
variance of concern, which include the British
variant, the South African, the Brazilian,
the California, the New York and the Indian
variants, we will likely not need a booster
for the Fizer vaccine in the next six to 12
months.
And since the Moderna and Fizer vaccines work
essentially identically, they're essentially
clones.
We will probably not need a Moderna booster
either in the next six to 12 months.
Now, this is important to understand.
The vaccines will be updated over the next
six to 12 months to to account for the new
variants at some point in the future.
A booster for already vaccinated people may
be needed, but it appears that already vaccinated
people will not need a tweaked booster in
the next six to 12 months.
People vaccinated for the first time in the
next six to 12 months will start getting a
tweaked version that accounts for the variance.
That's fantastic news.
But then maybe as importantly as we've expected,
based on the vaccination data, cases and deaths
are continuing down and that should accelerate
as we approach 40 percent fully vaccinated
in the U.S. and then hopefully on to 50 percent.
Recall that cases peaked at about 250, 5000
cases per day in January.
I mean, just remember when we were saying
if we're not careful, we might one day see
100000 cases a day?
Well, we got two and a half times that two
hundred fifty five thousand cases per day
in January.
We're down about 85 percent from that level
to about 40000 cases per day.
Still a lot.
But that rate of decline is once again accelerating
by Memorial Day.
It should be quite a bit below that.
And we've even had a couple of days in the
last week at the sort of twenty six, twenty
eight thousand cases per day level.
That's a good sign in terms of deaths.
Recall that the pandemic high of more than
3400 deaths per day was in late January.
That number is now also down about 81 percent
from its peak, still 650 deaths per day.
Still a tragedy, still a pandemic.
Still much work to be done, but going in the
right direction and on a slight delay from
the case decline, we're seeing another inflection
point where we are seeing faster decline in
deaths down even to the 200, 300 level a couple
of days this week, some of the lowest numbers
in a very long time.
Some states like Massachusetts recently reporting
a single day with zero deaths for the first
time and basically since the beginning of
the pandemic.
Now, another bit of good news from the vaccination
front is that after nearly a month of declining
vaccinations, because, as we said, supply
was starting to exceed demand, most of those
who really wanted to be vaccinated have been
able to get vaccinated.
And we had to start work on the vaccine resistant.
While the average daily vaccinations have
again started to go up, they bottomed out
at about one point nine million doses a day.
We're back up to two point two million doses
a day.
And as I mentioned earlier, Pfizer has now
been approved for emergency use for 12 to
15 year olds.
We'll talk about that in a moment.
And hopefully that will increase the numbers
as well.
More and more countries are opening for travel
in person.
School in the fall is looking like close to
an absolute certainty, with many schools requiring
vaccination for students to come back to campus.
But that's just the United States.
This is a global fight.
What is?
Happening globally, where vaccine access is
still a major problem, so the good news globally
is that after another new peak in cases, global
cases are now starting to trend down again
and are down about seven percent from that
new peak.
Global deaths are also just starting to tick
down.
And even in India, which was experiencing,
I mean, just incredible tragedy for the last
month, cases per day appear to have peaked
and have just slightly started to decline.
It is going to be a very long road for India,
but you always prefer to see cases going down
rather than up.
So that's the current panorama.
A couple of other small things we're learning
that early caution about the protection of
vaccines was appropriate before we knew.
Do they reduce spread?
How effective are they?
But as more and more health experts continue
to look at the data, they are increasingly
comfortable saying, listen, when you're vaccinated,
just about every activity is low risk.
That doesn't mean stop following CDC guidelines
about masking indoors, about protecting others.
All of this stuff.
But personal risk is really, really low if
you were vaccinated.
So nothing in this world is zero, no doubt,
but very good vaccine news.
And we'll see where we are next week as far
as the numbers are concerned.
Let's now talk about the expansion of the
Fizer vaccine to 12 to 15 year olds.